é a a agulha só quem apareceu mais uma
vez e estamos superando a voz lembrando
a você uma coisa você esquecer como tem
muita gente que esquece cápsulas isto
virtude se entretêm chegou no final
esquece de clicarem gostei da clínica
logo gostei aqui embaixo no sisbi fico
tendeu a não esquecer e muita gente a
assistir os vídeos não é inscrito no
canal e se você ainda não inscrito
clique em baixo aqui em cima não sei
inscrever se você tem inscrito o canal
seja fazer parte dessa família que é o
barulho e gasto duplicar gostei acho que
inscreveu pouco de escola show high
fashion e não me segue não estava
estabelecido aqui olha a mágica que o
bota em cima da minha mão rotário é ver
o bota em outro lugar ele consegue
sempre viu as fotos muito interessantes
em legal eu fui assistir os 50 de
liberdade né calma tanto tempo assistir
um pornô pesado na internet como se um
pouco mais tranqüilos e nada melhor que
você assistiu a [ __ ] com 150 pessoas
junto assistir monte de gente na mesma
sala de rodrigo e que mora aí beleza o
filme começa todo fumante que estão
casando a galera casa procure singley
anastácia anastácio já não consigo fazer
um gemido assim que o nome não parece
gente que transa nastácia transando
anastácia não dizem que transam bastasse
voltar pode ser a dona do cabaré a dona
do time ficou aqui é rio preto não é ou
não é a dona na estância eles vão portel
e ver o que acontece
mostrou de 40 segundos de filmes vão
falou de mel vão à praia todo mundo
pelado na praia anastácio vai fazer
topless ela tira para mostrar os peitos
não gosta não zango você a você me
desafiar foi beleza levou aparelho ou
quatro botões ao gênio baixou as calças
apa do pessoal segundo ambos de rolar é
essa meu batom apoio que tenho com a
luta de quem mata 50 rafah está no meio
da poeira ela deixa nessa época que fui
bem ea mulher geme que só povo um sexo
diferente assim maravilhoso eu acho
massa o sexo dele porque cena de filme
deixa o sexo mas a produção tem música
de câmera lenta e gemido
ae
[Música]
tem gente bonita transando que isso
influencia também sabe que a pessoa
quando ela é bonita outra pessoa bonita
sexy ou quer ver
imaginei que o pai toma transando meu
deus do céu no golpe pensar meu pai
minha mãe trazendo assim mais fica a
batina de um padre no céu tável mario
vem só assim essa diferença do rio na
realidade um sexo não é bonito nem
caminho bonito esse jeito que nem no
filme e ligeiro que ela chega no quarto
a camisa assim a mulher vem só consegue
atrair tem o sutiã cai
a espanha está aberta ela fechou porque
as pernas calça remendada sim sozinha é
rápido vai provocar a vida real é meia
hora só começar agora sim amigo do tempo
desgraça pra cima a baixo
eu te amo eu tinha então 18 anos é
formada em abril deste ano é tendo um
negócio que segura um do lado do outro
pois a onde quer
aqui ensinamos não a gente não é só um
que não é seu tio não vai curtir toda
essa desgraça para aí que essa é velha
época foram que não sou vaca que o arame
o é e pronto
encaixava almoço agora o papo foi papel
a beleza no filme alguém liga pro cuesta
grey a dizer que teve uma explosão no
escritório da empresa dele explosão
alguém estava tentado contra a vida
deles querem que aconteça alguma coisa
eu queria dar um sinal nevão explodir
aqui para um sinal fazer que eu sou
perigoso estou por aqui a força embora
aí o carro xangai bota segurança para
andar lá está porque quando teve a
explosão a ufu alerta é perigoso então
banda com segurança directora daquela e
um segurança e atrás do lugar que lhe
segurança atrás vai trabalhar e volta eo
marido elenco o xangai
ai tá lá espera num carro são [ __ ]
o cara ela vê o carro fala meu deus q
carro mas deixa dirigir não vai dirigir
sou eu é que dentro do carro eles vão
chegar na casa na hora que ela chega
lado ela vê a casa fala meu deus q casa
linda a mulher estava fazendo a casa a
arquiteta ela ficava olhando porque
cheguei a ficar morto na porta da casa
delas latinas vamos fazer uma piscina
aqui a gente faz um banheiro que todo
mundo e se firmasse filme sabe sair
futebol no filme é transar que é meu
deus por voltar a tocar aí beleza sai da
casa agora vou dirigir tá bom eu já
dirigi eleitor educar meu amigo só não
ocorreu
a minha filha devagar ele assustado com
a muleta dirigir voar ea van topic na
nova sede também para o henrique e ele
percebe que está sendo seguido ele que
eu diga o cristiano é isso aí falar
assim pois correm na história fala sério
de sério e o carro atrás do mundo de
espírito 40 na esquina o carro aparece
atrás de novo para continuar seguindo o
carro do filme rocky de sorriso está 20
por desviado folha ela consegue
despistar o cara estava seguindo ele
estaciona ela olha pra ele tira o cinto
acha calcinha sobe em cima do carro e
começa
depois que todo mundo faz e pensa se que
a rádio é quase morrendo que eu vou
fazer agora rodar sua de preto do cara e
contava acontecer essas coisas a
perseguição a explosão o que justificou
o [ __ ] meu deus você não pode fazer
nada não tem que ficar na casa para o
trabalho e do trabalho para casa não vou
treinar porque ela fez saiu comigo da
puma também é obrigada a ficar sem me
disse que tomou um toque de mágica manda
pra casa um raio matou como efeito a
demorou chegar em casa naquela chegou em
torno de casa o seqüestrador já pegou
com a faca no pescoço assim a segurança
mulher e cai de um tiro e viu ontem 48
tive tudo certo mas aí o que este andrey
ficou zangado porque ela desobedeceu às
ordens para que ele vai fazer vingar
porque ela desobedeceu ele levando o
quarto do senhor quarto do jogo nem tem
um quarto do jogo o jogo na sala fifa da
economia sobre gana é de um atacante
chega à casa de papel e essa é a punição
por ter desobedecido e sexo a mulher
falou que não gosta aí mas é como se eu
fizesse alguma coisa minha mãe mandou eu
não falei ela dissesse sim qual o
estúdio jovem e seu caro às siglas
quatro times ofereceu o cão acredito
cara meu deus é o japão 4 nova t3 cunha
do céu e nunca mandei ela foi explicar a
cara porque eu não vejo meus amigos eu
não vejo pessoas eu só pessoa fica presa
de casa eu fiz os meus amigos no outro
dia o cara parece empregados assim vamos
viajar a mala já tá feito no bagageiro
do carro ela entra e leva o avião galera
ontem 9 os amigos surpresa aos amigo
dela cara não dentro do avião ela fala o
que é isso cristian ele fala comprar
seus amigos pra você
eles chegam a casa para passar as férias
dia de férias assim com os amigos ao
eles vão passar logo e xangai está
tocando o piano e cantando um faz tudo é
bonita rica rola grande ainda toca piano
e canta numa folha demais é quem mais
vem falando assim agora votar uma
proposição mim aqui pra você mede 110 y
o cara deve ter tomado de madrugada a
meta lá embaixo - o verdão pega o
sorvete janeiro começa a lamber pai na
rua do carmo meu deus do céu eu deus não
tem condição as consigam de casada nem
na cozinha mas de novo mandou eu me
livro haver mais avançou na cozinha
enquanto ela diga qual é a rua de novo
não não à final e eles transam na
cozinha mas cozinha que dá vontade de
transar com a exclusiva o peso daquela
geladeiras onde duas portas inox aquele
fogão que são vidros em cima do mármore
cinza botar panela já
ladeira que liga o lam de leite 5 além
da vontade de transar na cozinha dessas
poupanças cozinha que encoste na
geladeira um shopping na boca do fogão é
tudo está a jogar a frigideira ensino
com óleo de 15 dias em itália o botijão
com a capa zona em cima como é que
transmite a doença nem voltaria a mulher
nunca também está na cozinha que eu vou
chegando a dar um cheirinho ela chega
perto mas não quer perder
enquanto o clima nem como do filme assim
qualquer coisa ténis é que ela não pode
reclamar de nada que ele pegasse ela nem
reclamar de cartola eu só vivia
reclamando da vida está com o povo desta
manhã eu queria saber de você o que você
acha mais engraçado uma interessante em
filme pornô bota aqui nos comentários
aqui embaixo você tá aqui no youtube não
esquece clicar em gostei o sexo do
twitter me segue goiás go posse go
engraçada em tento da equipe nesse vídeo
que para espalhar para mais gente
assistindo rt no vídeo e que do facebook
que antigamente curtir muito uma vez que
o portal galera curtir pracana esquecem
de curtir lá no facebook poderão postar
vídeo novo papel curte aqui não se quer
discutir clique em curtir a quitar
minhas redes sociais é nóis 'tamo junto'
valeu para que você tenha gostado até o
próximo vídeo em inglês